hey this is presh talwalkar
five people are seated randomly around a
circular table
what is the probability two people will
be seated next to each other
we can make the question a little bit
more precise by labeling the people as a
b c d and e
and asking about the probability that a
and b will be seated next to each other
this is part one of the question
the next part is to ask for the same
probability if the five people are
seated randomly in a row
the next part is to generalize
what is the probability if there are n
people seated randomly solve for both
cases of seating around a circular table
and in a row
this problem has been asked to
programmers
and during other technical jobs as an
interview question
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
we'll first consider
seeding around a circular table with
five people
there are a couple of ways we'll solve
this the first method is we'll consider
equally likely seats
we have a circular table with five
different seats
person a will be in some seat
without loss of generality we can make
it the seat at the top of the diagram
person b can be in any of the four
remaining seats
and it's equally likely that b will be
in any of these seats
of these seats exactly two of them will
be adjacent to a
therefore
the probability that a and b will be
seated adjacent
is two divided by four which equals
one-half and that's 50 percent
there's another way you could solve the
problem by counting pairs of seats
when there are five seats there are five
choose two which equals ten pairs of
seats
out of these there are five pairs that
are adjacent
each seat can be paired adjacently to
the one
that's right next to it going clockwise
therefore the probability that a and b
will be adjacent will be 5 divided by 10
which also equals one-half and that's
also 50 percent
let's now solve the problem of seeding
in a
row one way to solve this is to use
conditional probability
there are two different ways that a
could be seeded
person a could be in the first or the
last seat
these are two out of five possible seats
so if person a is in the first seat for
example
then person b will be adjacent for
exactly one of the four remaining seats
similarly a person is at the end seat
person b has to be right next to it
that's one out of the four remaining
seats
now there's another case that person a
could be in a middle seat
so in this
five person case there are three middle
seats
in any of these seats
person b can be adjacent to be either on
the left side or the right side there
are two places that person b could be
and could be adjacent
so we put these cases together
the probability is two over five times
one over four plus three over five times
two over four
and that simplifies to be two-fifths
which is forty percent
another way is that we could count the
pairs of seats
there are five choose two which is ten
pairs of seats now how many of these are
adjacent well there are four pairs of
adjacent seats because the first the
second the third and the fourth seats
could be paired with the seat after it
therefore there are four out of ten
possibilities which also equals 40
percent
now let's generalize for n people
we could solve these in the same ways
let's consider the method of equally
likely seats
person a will be at some seat
and now person b can be any of the n
minus 1 remaining seats and it's equally
likely that b will be at any of these n
minus one remaining seats
out of them
exactly two will be adjacent the seat to
the left and the seat to the right of
person a
therefore
there will be exactly two divided by n
minus one
possible ways
that a and b could be next to each other
so the probability is two over n minus
one
we can also do the same thing by
counting the pairs of seats
there are n choose 2 which equals n
times n minus 1 over 2 pairs of seats
out of these there are n pairs of
adjacent seats
we start from the top of this diagram
and go clockwise
each seat can be paired with the one
right after it
we end up counting n different pairs of
adjacent seats
so if we take n divided by n choose 2
this also simplifies to be 2 divided by
n minus 1.
let's now solve the case of seeding in a
row where you have n people
we can again solve it by conditional
probability
one case is that a is either in the
first seat or the last seat so these
will be two out of the n possible seats
so in the first seat
person b could be adjacent for only one
out of the n minus one remaining seats
it would have to be just right after
or if a was at the very end b would have
to be just before
now there's also the other case that a
could be in a middle seat
there are n minus 2 out of a total n
middle seats
in any of these middle seats
b could either be on the left side or
the right side so there will be two out
of the n minus one possible ways that b
could be adjacent
if we combine these cases we end up with
the following
equation
2 over n times 1 over n minus 1 plus n
minus 2 over n times 2 over n minus 1.
if you work through the algebra this
simplifies to be 2 over n and that's the
probability
we could also do the same thing by
counting pairs of seats
they're n choose 2 pairs of seats
and now how many adjacent seats are
there well they're n minus one
each seat can be paired with the seat to
its right so starting from the first
seat on the left
we can count all the way up to n minus
one that very last seat has no seat to
its right
therefore we take n minus 1 and divide
it by n choose 2 and that also
simplifies to be 2 over n
did you figure out these problems
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions which you can follow on
facebook google plus and patreon you can
catch me on social media at
preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description